[MUSIC PLAYING]
CINDY DUGGAN: Before I get into
how Manhattan College is using
Firebase to develop
its student mobile app,
I'd like to provide some
background on Manhattan College
and how its cloud
journey has been
evolving over the past decade.
A lot of things have happened
over the college that
is very important to
share, but it allowed
us to evolve our journey here.
The Glance Manhattan
College student app
was a big opportunity
for change here.
Before we get into
talking about it,
though, I'll share
some background
of our cloud adoption.
Then, I'll talk about how it
influenced web development
at Manhattan College.
And then another thing--
we'll also be talking about
how we evolved the app
and what led to how we
picked a native app.
I'll then get into talking
a little bit about Google
Assistant, which was the idea of
a personal assistant who always
near and dear to our hearts.
It was part of the
visioning of the native app.
But that's allowed us to
use more of the Google Cloud
product.
And I'll touch a
little bit on how
we're using Data
Studio, using data
from the app in
conjunction with BigQuery.
We'll then follow with
question and answers.
Manhattan College has
the best of both worlds.
It's a residential campus.
It's pretty tiny.
It has about 4,000
students, six schools--
School of Arts--
Liberal Arts-- School
of Education and Health,
School of Business.
Those are located on the
upper campus, along with part
of the School of Science.
And down below--
I'll show it on this map here--
is lower campus.
And that houses the
School of Engineering,
part of the School
of Science, and also
the Research and Learning Center
where my group and most of IT
is located.
You notice that it's
very close to Manhattan.
The end of the subway line is
just to the east of the campus.
So there's two subway
stops right down there.
And it's about a 35-minute
ride into Manhattan,
so it's very close.
And Manhattan is pretty small--
Manhattan College is small.
I work in the lower campus.
It's about 4/10
of a mile walk up
to the entrance to the college.
It probably takes about 10
minutes, so sort of densely
packed.
There's been a lot
of changes that
have happened over the
college over the last 10 years
that are sort of relevant
to our cloud journey.
There have been changes to
the physical infrastructure.
The college converted from
mostly a commuter campus
to a residential one
probably around 2012,
with the addition
of more dormitories.
And there's been a lot of
master planning going on.
The most recent one
was the addition of a--
oops.
Oops, sorry.
SPEAKER 2: [INAUDIBLE]
CINDY DUGGAN: Pointer--
was the building
of a student commons in 2014.
And with the
introduction of that,
there were a lot of
other things that
had happened in the college
in terms of branding.
We also got a new
president around 2009, also
some new people.
And that's when a lot of things
started changing, including
our adoption with Cloud.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- [INAUDIBLE]
[END PLAYBACK]
CINDY DUGGAN: Oops.
Oop, sorry.
I'm going to describe a
little bit about the group
that I work in.
Manhattan College is, of course,
a higher education place.
Our information technology
services, departments,
are structured similar to
like in other colleges.
I noticed that there
were a number of people
here at this presentation
from higher ed.
So we're part of Information
Technology Services,
which is headed by our CIO, Jake
Holmquist, who's here today.
We also have four groups,
of which mine is one.
My group is Web Applications.
It was formerly called
Web and Collaboration.
And a lot of these names have
changed a little bit over time.
We have Enterprise
Architecture, and they're
responsible for security,
networking, and what
used to be the data center.
And we have a director
here, Rob Moran.
We have Enterprise
Application Group,
which is really responsible for
our ERP system, our Enterprise
Resource Planning system, and
all our business applications.
We have client services
and operations,
which handles our help desk and
also knowledge-based service
catalog and operations
of all public labs,
and then my group, which
is involved in anything
related to web, pretty much.
It changes over time.
The whole IT organization
is like 22 full-time people.
So it's pretty
small, but everybody
has to wear a lot
of different hats.
And so we work pretty
closely-- my group
works very closely with
most of the other groups.
In addition, because we
are involved in the web,
we work very closely with
Marketing and Communication,
and then, in particular now, the
Office of Web Communications.
Now, I need to mention here
that Manhattan College received
a 2017 Cloud Leadership Award
from E&I Cooperative Services.
It was presented at the Educause
Conference in Philadelphia
last fall.
And they got this
for their involvement
in advancing hybrid
infrastructure and platform
as a service cloud
architectures.
So our Information
Technology Services
has done a lot in terms of
using cloud and, in particular,
Google Cloud.
A little bit about
my group-- we're
basically a development group.
Right now, we have four people.
We used to have three people.
Again, we're involved
in all things web.
About 20 years ago
when the web started,
we were involved in a
lot of other kind of--
a lot of things.
And about 10 years or so ago,
Marketing and Communications
took more of a role in that.
And Web Group and IT took
more of a support role.
We also work a lot with emerging
technologies, and trying out
new things, and
trying to use them
to develop custom applications.
Because of the type of
materials we worked with,
we've sort of been adopting
an Agile and DevOps
culture in cloud computing.
We use a lot of open
source software.
I always laugh because we
sort of have a frugal mindset,
because a lot of the things
that my group does eventually
gets replaced by a
product that comes out.
And so a lot of the
stuff that we're doing,
we feel like we're throwing
it away all the time.
So whenever we do things,
we try to develop our things
for reuse.
And that's a good
thing now, because now
with APIs and everything,
it sort of all
fits into the model.
I'm going to talk about
Manhattan's journey
in the decade of the
cloud, decade of mobile,
and the whole approach.
I've been at Manhattan
College for like 20 years.
And for the first
10, we basically
started the web and everything.
It seemed like not
much was happening.
We were in the era of Web 1.0.
You know, you had your web
server, people did stuff,
whatever.
And then about 10 years, Web
2.0 started to come into play,
and everything became
more intercollaborative.
People started contributing
information and things.
But that was also, I
think, when a lot of this--
everything as a service started.
We started to see
a lot of software
as a service being introduced.
The first one in that
case would be Gmail, OK?
But most of those
things were all services
that are delivered
over the internet,
rather than provided
locally or on-site.
So this thing has been growing
over the past 10 years,
or evolving.
Today, especially
in higher ed, we're
seeing a lot of adopting of
best-of-breed applications.
So rather than having
everything from one vendor,
we're adopting a
bunch of products
from a lot of different vendors.
And that presents a lot
of integration challenges.
So the role that we
play is quite different.
So here's sort of a
simplified timeline
of Manhattan College and its
involvement with Google Cloud.
And again, I concentrate
on the last 10 years
because that's when
we started using
our first sofware as a service.
And that was Gmail.
That was pretty
revolutionary, at the time.
We were probably one
of the first sets
of colleges to introduce that.
That was part of the G
Suite, formerly called
Google Apps for Education.
And so we started using a
lot of Google products--
Calendar, Docs, Forms, Sheets.
In addition, we've always used,
for web, the Google Search,
Google Maps, Google Analytics.
Another big thing that
we've more recently
adopted across the
campus was Google Drive.
But rather than
the last 10 years,
I think the key defining
point for the college in terms
of moving to the Cloud was in
the time frame of 2014 to 2016.
There were a lot of
things that happened
in the college that
just sort of gave us
opportunities to do this--
was basically what we call
Google Cloud, phase 1, when
Rob's group, the Enterprise
Architecture Group,
introduced a virtual
machine as a service.
So what that entailed was
migrating a lot of the web
applications over
to Google Cloud
and to the compute platform.
And also at that
time, the college
was going through a rebranding
effort for their web sites.
And part of that involved
us providing web servers.
And rather than hosting
them in our data center,
they were now hosted
in the cloud--
on Google Cloud.
And that was with also high
availability, load balancing
and that.
So that was a big
success for us.
Eventually, that evolved more
into Google Cloud, phase 2,
what we term the hybrid data
center where the database was
left in our data center, and
the other parts of the system
were out in the Google Cloud.
And that was facilitated
by the introduction
of site-to-site VPN between
the data center and the cloud.
So now, we actually had
two parts of the system
running in different
places, but connected.
And so we ran our first launch
of our enterprise research
planning system in the
cloud in around 2017.
So our COO was very, very into
cloud and advancing cloud.
And a cloud-first
strategy became
part of our annual goals.
Starting in 2016 and 2017,
we were told basically, no
more servers.
Everything that we get
now, any kind of service,
is deployed in the Cloud.
No new hardware.
So that's sort of
been the mandate.
It's been a little tough to
handle from the beginning,
but it's all OK now.
But everything has
been working well,
and we've been
pretty successful.
Oops.
What happened here?
OK.
So I'm going to talk a little
bit about the web technology
landscape prior
to 2014 and how we
used to develop our
applications and whatever.
We were pretty comfortable
and used a PHP-based LAMP
stack, which was Linux
as the operating system;
Apache HTTP Server
as the web server;
MySQL as the
relational database,
and PHP as the
scripting language.
And that was used for most of
our custom development work,
but also to run
our web site, which
we were using open source
Drupal as our content management
system framework.
We used to self-host that.
And eventually, we
started moving that
to a platform-as-a-service
provider in 2014-2016.
So we got some experience
with the cloud from that.
That was a little tough.
On the other end, we had
what we called My MC Portal.
And I don't know-- if
some of you are younger,
when you were in college,
you might recall the portals
that your school used to have.
It was basically almost
like a monolithic system
of little windows into a bunch
of different applications,
a lot of it is connected
by single sign-on.
That was pretty difficult
for us to pull off.
Now, first of all, we adopted a
open-source framework for that,
called uPortal.
But that was a Java-based stack.
It used Linux as the
operating system,
but it used Apache Tomcat
as the web server and Oracle
database, a relational
database, for the database.
And then, it used Java.
So we only have a small staff.
We had three people in it,
and only like one of them
was a really good developer.
So we learned a lot doing that.
We ran that for
about three years,
but it was pretty limited.
And in the end, Marketing
and Communication
was looking for something
more of like people
can go in and have WYSIWYG
editor and enter content--
whatever.
So eventually, as part of
the web branding initiative
we got rid of that and moved
to something different.
So again, a lot of things
happened in 2014 to 2016.
And I just say, this was
sort of a defining period
for us, and especially
for the web.
Was it fate?
Was it kismet?
Was it serendipity?
Everything just sort of
came together very nicely.
Everything was happening
at the right time.
The college was going
through a branding initiative
for the websites,
in which case, we
ended up with a vendor-hosted
content management system.
There were also a
lot of campus master
plans planning taking effect.
The college had--
you recall that I
showed the new student commons.
With all that, they
finally licensed
a room event-scheduling system.
So now, we had a lot
of calendars and stuff.
And all this, everything
as a service was maturing.
And the best part for us and
for our adoption of Firebase
was we got summer interns.
The college had a Jasper
summer research program.
And prior to that, a lot
of other departments,
especially in Science
and Engineering,
were hiring students to
come up with a project they
wanted to work on.
And they would fund it for
the summer, and whatever.
So ITS took on--
well, my group took
on two summer interns,
and we had to come up with
a project for them to do.
So before I get into
the start of Firebase
and how we used that--
we're seeing a lot of shift
in technologies in development
at this time.
Our content management system
and the publishing model
was different.
The websites were all developed
through a vendor SaaS solution.
But what was happening
here is the web content
from that system was
basically published out
to web servers, sort of
like a static web site, OK?
It hooks into use feeds, and
widgets, and things like that.
But a lot of the
stuff, even with PHP,
was basically done
behind the scenes.
And the website was
published out every night.
We published out every night.
So that gave us more
opportunity to start
working with data
integration via widgets
and feeds either in RSS XML
format, or more importantly,
the JSON format, which
we've sort of adopted.
And that's also part
of how Firebase works.
And the other end was like
the death of our portal.
I don't know if that
was good or bad.
In retrospect, it was
good, but we were still
sort of a little sad
to see a lot of that go
and a lot of the work
we had done disappear.
There were certain parts of
the portal that were useful.
And one of the things was--
what they had was you were able
to search within a portlet.
And a portlet is basically
like on of those windows--
whatever.
But you basically would
enter some metadata
about what was in the portlet.
And lot of that was
used at the portal level
to help people find things.
Another thing that
the portal always had
was a lot of quick links.
You were starting to see
a lot of these everything
as a service products out there.
And people were using
the portal as a place
where people would come and
find all those different links.
So it was basically
just a list of links.
But anyway, for the
searching, people
were starting to
see more of looking
at other kinds of solutions,
because the portal--
and pulling it off was a very
difficult concept, unless you
really licensed a version
from one of the big vendors.
But you were starting to
see more lightweight campus
portals where people
were starting to say,
these other products
do their thing well.
They don't really want--
like for example, Google--
they don't really want you
pulling in your email threads
into a window in the portal,
and pulling your calendar stuff
into another window
of the portal,
and pulling in your files,
looking at another one.
And basically, it had
its old interface,
and so roll with the flow.
[CHUCKLES]
But those were some of the
good features of the portal
that people like to keep.
And again, it was a big
learning experience for us.
It was open source product.
We learned a lot
about developing code
and contributing code--
whatever.
So a big thing for
the new and what
they called an
intranet website was
a way of aggregating all these
campus tasks and services.
And to do that--
and this is also happening in
conjunction at the same time
that we started
developing a student app--
was a way to aggregate these
someplace so that people
could find the information.
And the approach
we basically took
was defining things like, pay
my bill, things like that.
And it might be
embedded in some system,
but people would search for
"pay my bill", or "tuition",
or whatever, or "find
the final exam schedule".
And they would find it
through this interface.
And for this, we used a
search as a service product
from Algolia.
So now we get into developing
the Glance MC Student App.
And it was named like
that because of some
of the conditionals we
put on this development.
So again, our native
mobile app was a summer
of 2015 student project.
The students had to
come up with a project.
I came back from vacation.
It's like, here's
your two student.
It's like, they need a project.
So at that time, everybody
wanted to develop apps.
Well, they came up with this--
there's this word cloud here.
And things that
were hot at the time
were, mobile, discovery, portal,
lightweight, digital, search,
native, personal assistant.
The big thing was
the campus ID card,
what we call our Jasper Card.
Manhattan College-- I didn't
mention this-- are the Jaspers.
So I'll keep using the ID
card and Jasper card together.
But students basically
carry their phones
around all the time.
A lot of times, they were
forgetting their paper ID card.
With all the new buildings
that were happening,
they were starting to use
these optical scanners to allow
entry into the dorms,
and to the athletic gym,
and other places like that.
So the students kept
saying, oh, it'd
cool if we had our ID
card on our phones.
So all that was part of the
visioning for this student app.
So then we had a choice.
OK, what do we use for the
stack to develop this app?
At the time, you reallly
had Apple, you had Android,
or we could develop
a cross-platform app.
There were, at the time, a
predominance of Apple devices
on our campus.
Students might have had a phone,
so the ecosystem from Apple.
It could have been
like the laptop,
they had a phone, they
had an iPad, or whatever.
And the students wanted
to develop apps for Apple
and felt that
development was easier
there because they only had
a couple of different sizes.
You had a couple of
different devices,
and they were all the same.
So we looked at Android, and you
had a lot of different phones
you had to worry about.
Plus, the students that we
had were also just going
into their junior year.
They really hadn't had any--
the college really didn't
have a computer science
program at the time.
The students didn't have any
kind of training or anything,
but they just felt comfortable
developing for Apple.
And I guess Swift had
just come out-- whatever.
For Android, they
had Android Studio--
whatever.
And it wasn't that
well-documented at the time,
or the students felt.
So the other choice
was a cross-platform app,
and they really couldn't
get their hands around that.
And the whole idea of
thinking about that was tough.
So who do you think won?
First app was an iOS app, under
the condition that the next one
would be Android.
So we had these two
students working all summer.
They were funded as a Jasper
Research Scholar at the time.
We've employed them
during the school years,
using campus employment
work-study funds.
And we also allowed
them to learn.
We provide a lot of training.
There's a lot of
self-study, self-learning
that goes on in my group.
We have a lot of
resources for that.
But anyway, they ended
up with conceiving
a lightweight mobile app.
And they wanted
something where they can
access information on-the-go.
One of the conditions from
Marketing and Communication
was that it complemented the new
websites that were coming out.
And also, the college did
not have its own mobile app
and didn't see a need for one.
The websites were
all responsive,
and they felt that
was good enough.
But part of our justification
for using a native mobile app
was that we would use the
features of the device,
like maps and
locations, and also
that we'd have a digital
campus ID card for the use
with optical scanners, OK?
And so the way we
worked it was this
was kept as a student
developer product.
My group had oversight.
And it sort of evolved a lot
into some healthy competition
between the two groups
where we learned a lot
from what they were doing.
We also sort of vet what
they're doing to make sure
they're on the right track.
But there's a lot
of competition.
So now, I'm going to get into
developing the Glance Student
App and our app basics
or data modeling.
So the first thing
they had to do
to come up with what
they wanted to put in
is collect all the data.
And we needed to have someplace
where they could collect it
and where we could see it.
So the database code for that
was basically a Google Sheet.
So they collected all the
information in a Google Sheet.
A lot of it was like
Maps information--
coordinates, building codes,
the addresses, things like that.
This is a little bit more
sophisticated than what
they had at the point.
But a lot of the stuff
we had from the portal
were feeds-- you know, daily
announcements, news, twitters,
features, events,
events calendars--
lots of events calendars
with the new system
they had just put in place.
And so they collected it
all in a Google Sheet,
and then they used
this data when they
started developing the app.
So when the app was
released, they basically
wrote all the stuff
into the code.
We released it a year later--
a year and three months later,
called Glance MC, because
Glance meaning that we really
didn't want them to incorporate
things in there that
would get replaced by an app
that came out in the future.
For example, if our ERP
vendor came up with something
and this college
adopted it, we didn't
want to have to throw
away what we did.
So they were supposed to keep
more to top-level type stuff
here.
So we released it.
And at the same time,
we released Jasper Pay
at the college, which allowed
people to pay for their meals
and stuff using their
digital ID card.
And that's become a big hit.
We also employed in
there-- this will
be called the At A
Glance search, which
was part of the
aggregated campus services
that we show that we use
on our intranet portal.
And we have a employee directory
and all those services in it.
And we also incorporated
a bunch of RSS
and XML feeds and
a campus newspaper.
With time, we've added in
geolocation maps integration,
so that someone can see, if
they looked up an employee,
it would tell them-- if they
clicked the location icon,
it would show their
location on a map
and where they were relative to
the place where the person was
located.
Same thing for the calendar.
If the event was
happening someplace,
you could see where it was.
Part of the problem
with all that,
too, is we couldn't
really use directions,
because our campus is
not mapped out by Google.
You notice there's
a ring road that
runs around the campus
and upper campus
with all these buildings
contained within.
So here comes the
turning point now.
We've developed this
release, this app for iOS.
And now, we had to
worry about Android.
So we wanted to match the
features from the iOS app
to the Android one.
And then for further
development of the iOS app,
there's a lot of
things they wanted
incorporate, like favorites.
Once they found things
that they liked to search,
they woud like to pin them so
that they have access to them
all the time, their
own favorites.
They wanted to have an
in-app campus ID card.
So the way we
deployed the campus ID
card was through Apple Wallet.
And we actually are
using a PKPASS file
to do that, which
my group had set up.
Eventually, when we released
this app for Android,
they coupled it with a--
I think it was called a--
Wallet passed this
thing from Android
so they could get
the campus ID card.
But if we had an
in-app Jasper card,
then people didn't need
the other application.
Eventually, we
want to have access
to authorized data
via authentication.
Like people wanted to see their
course schedule on the phone.
We still had a lot of commuters
or people that live off campus.
And a lot of times
if they wanted
to go to our student
information system,
they have to go through
a lot of different steps
to get to their schedule.
And it was a form that they
couldn't read on the phone, OK?
So part of the problem
with all of this
now was the app data is
actually on the device.
It was really difficult
to get something
released into the Apple Store.
There's a long process.
And plus, anytime we wanted
to change things-- there
were things that
were always coming.
And somebody would say,
can you incorporate this?
You know, we changed
calendars, we changed fees,
we do whatever.
And so that was an issue.
And so we sort of saw the
need for a mobile back end
as a service for this.
And part of the whole
thing was this--
app development
takes a lot of time.
So part of our
Agile methodology--
let's rethink it and see
what we need to do next.
And oh, the other
choice was also,
should we switch to
something like React Native
to develop a cross-platform app.
So now developing the app,
take two-- enter Firebase.
So the concept that
students had at the time
was to use Parse as
a mobile backend.
And then, that was
announced that they
were getting rid of that.
But a good thing was
Firebase was acquired
by Google in October of 2014.
So that was the
thing we looked into.
And the first step was to
remove the data from the app
so that we could share
it across app versions.
So here's where we have
the model for Firebase.
And at the time, there was
Firebase Realtime Database
where you could access the
same database from an iOS
or an Android device
and also via the web.
And the data gets
synced in real time.
So how do you think we
propagated our Firebase
Realtime Database?
We go back to our
original Google Sheet, OK?
Somebody wrote a
little F-Script to take
the data from the spreadsheet
and upload it to Firebase.
OK, and that's an
example of just sending
the data from the little
excerpt on the left of code
is just what it takes
to send something
from one Sheet to the other.
If somebody goes in now
and changes something,
they added a new thing.
It's real-time.
It shows up in the app, and
it syncs over to Firebase.
And so this is a little
screenshot of our Firebase
Realtime Database.
The Firebase Realtime
Database is a NoSQL database,
which means it's not
structured in tables,
like relational databases are.
But the big thing now is all
the app data is in the cloud.
And this is a more
recent version,
but you'll see here some of the
things that we have in here--
campus alerts.
We actually have
tutorials there that
refer to pictures out
in the cloud someplace.
We have our building calendars,
feeds, tutorials, and then
eventually users, because
we incorporated favorites
going on.
So it gets a little
more complicated.
And it was actually pretty
easy to set all this up.
So that was a big reason
to use Firebase too.
So after that, we started using
more of the Firebase ecosystem.
The keyword here was
Firebase Authentication
where people can sign in
by their Manhattan College
or Google email
address and password.
That facilitated the development
of an in-app campus ID card
and allowed people to
pin their favorites.
And I've showed example
of the ID card here.
It basically just has
a barcode, whatever.
And also, there's a place
where people could add funds
to their account.
It actually has a
picture and all that.
So people were using this
now to swipe into dorms.
When they swiped in, the
person on the other end
would see a picture
of the student
from our database in the
college to identify the person.
And also, they were
using it to pay
for their meals
and other things.
It actually gives them
their balance and whatever.
It's pretty immediate
when it gets updated.
And also, here's
the thing where they
can favorite their employees
and also their favorite services
from the Algolia search.
Another part of the Firebase
ecosystem we started adopting
was Cloud Firestore.
And that was in beta.
And that was a little
different model
for how the data is stored.
Part of the problem with
using the real-time database
was it only allowed you to
use string type of data.
And if you wanted
something more structured,
the programmers
had to write a lot
to be able to work with that.
So Cloud Firestore, again,
is a NoSQL database,
but it's a lot
more sophisticated.
And it allows for
more types of data.
And the use case for
that was a quick view
of student's semester schedule
with an integrated map
and instructor directory.
And here, we have a screenshot
where they released my courses
for the spring.
And it actually shows a
student's schedule over here.
They haven't yet linked it to
the faculty member's profile
and also the building directory.
So the Firebase
Document Collection
for the Cloud
Firestore basically
consists of a collection
with documents.
So the way they
have it set up is
you have a collection
of students.
So each one of these
would be a student.
A student would have a bunch of
information organized by term.
First of all, we started
doing it for one term,
and that's how we
initially released it.
Students can register
for the next semester
at a certain time, and they
like to see their schedule
on their phones.
It was hard to just display
the current semester.
They really needed a range
of semesters and all that.
So it's organized by term.
And each term, a student
would have a bunch of classes.
So that's how that's structured.
A lot went into the
thinking as to how
they wanted to organize this.
And the good part
was, because we
have an iOS developer
and an Apple developer,
the two of them sort of vet
things out amongst themselves
and eventually choose the
right way to approach it.
And this sort of shows--
it's hard to show,
I was going to show
this on a timeline--
but how the app was
developed over time.
We started out for iOS.
And eventually we started
with the Android one
and sort of played a
little bit of catch-up.
But because of how
we adopted Firebase--
and we didn't have it
ata the beginning--
the people doing the iOS
development had to go
and refactor a lot of the
code and start over again,
because they ripped stuff out--
whatever.
The Android person
started out fresh
with Firebase and
all the products.
And it has been a very
quick evolution for that.
And actually, he's probably
ahead of the iOS person
right now.
So we used the Realtime
Database for basic app data.
We used Authentication
for the Jasper card
and also for favorites, and
then the Cloud Firestore
for the core schedule.
There's a bunch of other
ecosystem tools in Firebase.
For stability, we have
Crashalytics, crash reporting.
And they also have Firebase
Test Lab, which we used.
And it also has
built-in analytics,
Google Analytics for Firebase.
Rather than show
a demo, I'm just
going to do a quickie overview,
a promotional video of the app.
It's sort of quick.
But we've introduced this
for orientation back in June.
So it gets students into using
the app and their ID card.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
OK so a lot of
the sort of effect
of where we're going with web
and web applications today,
we sort of see a lot of this
thing as an app convergence
journey where we'd like to get
these two native apps into one
in some way.
And we're looking at maybe
the Firebase Cloud Functions
into helping us do that.
We've also started to
develop a lot of web apps.
And it's a lot quicker
to develop that way.
And we've been
incorporating them into here
by just a set of links.
Our web application
development stack
has changed quite a bit
as a result of mostly
how we were using Firebase.
And it's a lot different today.
We're using a lot of APIs,
different kinds of libraries
and stuff, and even being
able to run on no JS
on the Google App Stack.
[INAUDIBLE] some of
this [INAUDIBLE]..
We've also taken some
of these concepts
and have experimented with
a bunch of Google Assistant
actions.
The most recent one is
Talk to Manhattan College,
and it's a way to
extend the assistant
and use the dialect flow, a
conversational action piece,
to leverage the data from
Firebase and the app.
I'm running out of time here, so
I won't show this little demo.
And again, we're using Analytics
via BigQuery and Data Studio
to look at some of the
information from the app.
So this is a segueway into
actually learning more about
how we would use Cloud SQL
to analyze and bring together
other data sets from the
college at a higher level.
So in conclusion,
the Firebase platform
has been a great entry point for
integrating with other Google
Cloud tools.
And they've been a valuable
partner in our continual cloud
journey.
The best part was that
it was a way for us
all to learn how to develop
with the newest tools.
OK, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]